hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar update on hbv testing and
treatment
today and tomorrow i'm susie valdez of
labyrinths and i will be your moderator
for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by
lab roots and brought to you by diasoren
to learn more visit them at
diasporin.com
now we want to encourage you to
participate today by submitting as many
questions as you might have
during the presentation to do so simply
type them
into the ask a question box and click
send
we'll answer as many questions as you we
have time for at the end
of the presentation you may also submit
any technical issues here as well
if you have any trouble seeing or
hearing this presentation
now this webinar is educational and thus
offers free continuing
education credits please click on the
continuing education
window at the bottom of your screen to
obtain those credits
without further ado i'd like to now
welcome our speaker dr
robert gish an adjunct professor of
medicine at the university of nevada
schools of medicine in las
vegas and in reno dr kish welcome
you may now begin the presentation
greetings i'm dr robert gish
i'm a hepatologist based in san diego
and we're going to present today an
update on hepatitis b testing
and treatment talking about today
and tomorrow i have my own consulting
company
i work with hepticed foundation i teach
at loma linda university and university
of nevada
as well as ucsd skaggs school of
pharmacy
disclosures are on my website as well as
many other resources
there's a tremendous medical need for
testing
and linkage to care for hepatitis b it's
one of the top causes of cirrhosis and
liver cancer in the world
we have 292 million people who are
chronically infected with hepatitis b
globally in the us we think it's 2.4
million
risk-based screening for hepatitis b
has failed we are on a pathway
at least an attempt to get hepatitis b
and c elimination by 2030.
if you don't test everyone you're not
going to be able to find
hepatitis b to proceed on the
elimination pathway
the current standard of care in the u.s
is to test all adults for hepatitis c
and hiv and of course we've moved to
universal testing and linkage to care
and cure for hepatitis b which we'll
talk about more
there is a functional cure but there is
a disease control
that results in excellent patient
outcomes
there are large gaps in the screening
and linkage to care
think about this we only have a third of
patients aware of their infection
now those eligible for treatment
few are being treated this means
few on treatment few being linked to
care
here are the risk based advice
for screening recommendations on the
left the cdc
on the right the united states
preventative services task force
what we've seen happen using risk-based
screening for
20 years or more is a failure we have
few people
less than a third are diagnosed
hepatitis b foundation
for the last eight years has taken the
opposite approach
test all adults make it simple three
tests
three blood tests which we'll talk about
shortly for all adults
all pregnancies and at risk adolescence
screening here yes we have geography yes
we have immigration you could screen
based on this but how many people can
remember
these geographies these countries this
is very difficult
i'm in the hepatitis b space and i have
difficulty remembering this
why not screen all adults we if we
advocate for this will be in alignment
with the recent proclamation from
president biden's office
that the u.s should be part of the
global elimination pathway
very shortly we believe there will be an
advice
to vaccinate all adults for hepatitis b
but you should have testing before
vaccination
or at least incident two with two thirds
remaining undiagnosed
we need to do something different
a little bit more on this rationale to
test all adults
is not only can you diagnose hepatitis b
but you can also pick up another types
of liver disease and staged
liver disease perform a variety of
specific
tests that have to do with liver cancer
risk
do they need an endoscopy do they need
to be followed more closely and of
course
linkage to antiviral therapy also
behavior modification we can get them to
lose weight if they have fatty liver
stop drinking
alcohol if alcohol is a component of
their liver disease
we can stop transmission this is a liver
disease but it's also an infectious
disease
and it's a systemic disease we also need
to test for hepatitis a
because these adults should be immune to
hepatitis a and if not
vaccinated there are a lot of barriers
to screening and care
we have cultural and religious issues we
have stigma there's stigma from the
society basis there are
self stigma many patients believe in
traditional medicine or herbal or
supplements as a way to manage their
hepatitis b which there's scant data
that this actually has
any improvement on liver health there is
racism there is discrimination based on
hepatitis b as well as other
viral and other infectious hepatitis and
infectious diseases
there's a fear about stigma about being
discriminated against about losing a job
about not being in a relationship
this is all wrapped up in this stigma
process as well
we educate our patients one of the major
steps that we do in clinic once we
identify somebody who's surface antigen
positive
is to go out and test all family members
all
contacts all intimate contacts of course
there's other
issues about wound care about household
behavior and activities but on the other
side there should not be discrimination
hand-holding kissing sharing utensils
sharing glasses
are all perfectly safe and of course we
can
stop transmission using condoms for
sexual exposure prevention
and harm reduction needle exchanges for
hepatitis b
risk in that setting
patient perspective we need to be
sensitive to this but ultimately
we want to help the patient and the
community and the family
so it does take time for education that
we do have tests that are accurate
we do have treatments that are effective
all right so we have a case
this is how do you stage somebody
who's surface antigen positive think
about this
liver cancer risk biomarkers
answers yes alpha theta protein
part of that risk cancer triple
biomarker so we put that in as a second
question that's really built into the
first one aprion fib 4 helps stage the
fibrosis level
elastography helps stage fibrosis
liver stiffness first you're going to
have a surface antigen
core antibody and anti-hbs
screen triple panel stage
risk assessment
remember near terminology that ast and
alt
are not liver function tests these are
liver enzymes
alkaline phosphatase and ggt are also
liver enzymes
not liver function the best liver
function tests
are bilirubin albumin and inr and in
fact the direct bilirubin is the best of
the best liver function
let's go back to the triple panel when
you're assessing for hepatitis b
all patients should have hepatitis b
surface antigen
core antibody and surface antibody
surface antigen equals infection core
antibody
exposure because core antibody means
that that patient has ccc dna a residual
viral component in their liver
if the suspicion is correct you're on
the right pathway you may have to look
for occult hepatitis v is when they're
surface antigen negative
and impetize b dna positive
anti-hbs positivity equals immunity only
if core antibody
is negative there is no natural immunity
to hepatitis b
once you're infected with hepatitis b or
infected life long
it's extremely rare that somebody would
actually get infected with hepatitis b
clear their liver of all virus all ccc
dna
and all integrated virus this integrates
right after infection occurs the virus
starts integrating into the dna
reminds me of that movie alien
this is interpretation of the hepatitis
b serologic test
somewhat complex grid which i'm not
going to go into in detail now since
we've
covered most of this but this is a great
printout to have or to carry
on your electronic device carry in your
pocket carrying your brain
now we have this patient who we have
identified as being hepatitis b
surface antigen positive what do we do
next
we're going to check for hepatitis c
hepatitis a
you're going to check for delta with
antibody to delta
hiv renal function
i'm not going to order blood tests right
now for liver fibrosis since you've
already done the aprea fib 4
you already have other information but
that is an option for confusing patients
or you're confused about your patient
csh
that's for the primary care providers
and double-stranded dna of course
that's not relevant here because that
would be for autoimmune disease
part two variety of tests are available
to supplement what we just spoke about
doppler ultrasound chemistry more
advanced chemistry something that i like
and i order on all my hepatitis b
patients is quantitative hepatitis b
surface antigen
i think this is very very important
part three alcohol history renal
function
bone health pregnancy
assessment family testing
rarely are we going to do a liver biopsy
but i do come back to these
blood-based markers i'm using something
called liver fast from a company called
fibergnostics
fiber tests fiber sure are old tests
that i almost never use
some are just around the corner are
things called elf or nist
for other ways of assessing fibrosis
let's go to best practices establish a
clear
follow-up plan a call back system a way
to monitor
blood tests every six months each time
you meet with a patient
educate and re-educate re-motivate that
patient
to continue compulsive follow-up and
laboratory tests
i really like the word stop alcohol as
opposed to avoid or limit
because nobody knows what their limits
are especially people with history of
alcohol abuse
and assess for nash and fatty liver
best practices know your abcs
hepatitis a immunity hepatitis b
triple panel hepatitis delta if surface
antigen positive
hepatitis c and corona status
know your abcs
stigma and discrimination can be
discussed in a sensitive way with your
patients you may need an
interpreter who's a sensitive individual
clinic i work at in san diego
we have 42 different languages available
to us either directly
or through a portal
so once you have a patient's surface
antigen positive the guidelines
talk about quantitative hepatitis b dna
we covered that a little bit earlier
checking liver enzymes
so dna over 2000 alt
elevated strong propensity to treat
cess fibrosis significant fibrosis
that's f2
or higher law a very
strong likelihood to treat
currently we have three medications that
are first line
and techavir tenofovir tdf
tenofovir taf which are two different
pro drugs of tenofovir
that's 99.8 percent of the market point
two percent
is interferon i've treated a number of
patients with hepatitis b with
interferon but unfortunately
surface antigen loss or goal is rare
even with interferon
and it's costly and it's costly to the
patient in terms of side effects
as well
when to refer these patients to a
specialist
well if pregnancy that should be managed
in that pregnancy we're going to be
testing the mother
finding out her viral level considering
treatment in those individuals
their viral load is over 200 000.
cirrhosis specialists needs to think
about endoscopy
compulsive follow-up for liver cancer
surveillance
liver cancer first assessment of course
everybody gets a baseline
ultrasound liver failure serocytes is
there encephalopathy what is the liver
function
test look like then of course we're
thinking about alt flares
aerial t increases at five times or more
above the upper limits of normal or
baseline
this can happen during treatment or if
treatment is stopped
so dell hepatitis testing is simple it's
an antibody test
it's available through quest right now
and we're trying to get that available
through labcorp it really should be
available through all
the labs i'm also working with a lab
called bioreference trying to get them
up and running
patients slip through the cracks this is
the check study
chronic hepatitis cohort study a number
of different people have been using this
chex
program to look at patients inside
different health care systems
so here you have hepatitis b patients
but only 78 percent had alts done per
year
37 had hpv dna done
once a year or more almost 20
had never had an hpv dna test
assessed people with hpv and cirrhosis
treatment should be a hundred percent
but in this setting only
56 had prescribed medicine
hpv dna extremely important part of
assessing that patient after identifying
surface antigen positivity
only 54 percent had dna annually
terrible 35 were having it out our
recommendation of twice a year
11 had never had this hpv dna done
at all all right we have a challenge
we need your help hcc screening
and surveillance screening is the first
test
surveillance is ongoing testing
so here's the paradigm currently on the
left
suppressive therapy hechover tdf or taf
you put them on it the patients
go dna negative in most cases and you
keep them on the medicine
indefinitely i don't like forever
because forever means forever and we
have many new medicines coming
so indefinite it's a softer term a
little less threatening
future is going to be heading towards a
functional cure instead of
zero to ten percent we're trying to get
to
40 with our next treatment options the
ultimate goal is s
antigen loss off treatment
dna needs to be suppressed to
undetectable
we don't accept any level of replication
and sometimes
two or three percent may require two
drugs for switching drugs
but really we want to get to a finite
course of treatment
not indefinite as we are today
patients are concerned about taking
pills every day but they take vitamins
every day they take herbal remedies
every day
they can definitely take one of these
tablets of these three different
medicines
and the side effects are really rare in
tech of ear
almost no side effects of course there
are remote chances of lactic acidosis
with that in really sick patients in the
hospital
and treatment eligibility might mean
even insurance status
and of course the patient's motivation
so when we're thinking about treating
patients we think about what are the
risk factors for progression and we look
at those and try to use those to decide
who to treat
you can see how complicated this gets
age gender dna level alt
fibrosis status how high
are the ast and alt is their liver iron
is their liver
fat they have hiv they have delt
hepatitis
what's their smoking status family
history for liver cancer
all going to come into this formula
trying to move somebody to treatment
so if i find one of these things wrong
i'm very likely to treat them
of course might find five or ten any of
really good
data to further motivate that patient to
stay on treatment
there are fears fear of being diagnosed
with liver cancer or dying prematurely
or being a burden to the family
there are barriers about getting
callbacks a patient remembering your
office or
our staff or a doctor's or provider's
office calling the patient back cause
they forget
the callback systems are very well many
of these patients
feel good why do they need treatment if
they feel good
there's a lot of sort of background
self-treatment self-medication that
occurs
let's talk about the six pillars of
management management of hepatitis b
number one test all adults of course you
can do risk-based but
we believe that fails core antibody
educate the patient at their core
antibody alone about the risk of
reactivation
the chemo with hiv medicines with
hepatitis c medications
all these things can lead to flares and
reactivation
vaccinate all adults who are triple
negative
remember alt healthy for men is less
than 35
for women less than 25 there's a
difference
in alt ast alkyl and phosphatase and ggt
by gender
it's really interesting s
antigen loss is your ultimate goal so i
quantitate hepatitis b surface antigen
in all of my patients
annually are they clearing on their own
are they clearing on treatment
or if they're not clearing what else can
we do
here's more on quantitative s antigen
it helps establish the state or phase of
disease
higher levels are associated with liver
cancer
higher levels are with a decreased
probability of viral control or
clearance it does have some relationship
to the response to nucleoside or
nucleotide analogs
there is stronger evidence about
response to interferon
quantitative antigen also correlates
with risk of transmission
if you have a mother whose viral load is
say 600
but the surface antigen quant is 10 000
you've got a big problem and this type
of scenario does occur
so let's talk about delta hepatitis for
a moment
worldwide we think there's 15 to 20
million people
and in the us we think there's 150 000
with delta it's about a seventy percent
mortality rate in less than twenty years
maybe closer to ten years very few
patients who are surface antigen
positive have been screened
fewer diagnosed because the screening
test doesn't mean someone talks to them
about it
the management means more aggressive
interventions including interferon
and that's where the treatment is just a
few percent
this we hope will change with our
advocacy
point of care there are tests around the
world for surface antigen
and a few more that actually look at
core and surface antibody
uh very important there's other point of
care tests
including point of care for hepatitis b
dna quantification that takes 20 minutes
and it's relatively inexpensive in the
20 to 30 dollar range
so there are things that are coming
hopefully wherever
you are you're going to be hearing about
this these point of care tests and have
those phased into local algorithms and
protocols
so in summary let's walk through this
hepatitis b
vaccination is safe and effective we
have
a really new good hepatitis b vaccine
called peplusav
it's two doses much better compliance
and adherence because you don't have
three doses
and the two doses are within four weeks
of each other typically
and much higher titers and protective
titers especially in diabetics and other
people that are in a higher risk group
vaccine coverage in children there's
over a thousand children
in the u.s that are infected with
hepatitis b lifelong because the mother
and the baby were not properly managed
in that perinatal period
so the mother has a high hpv dna we
treat her with tenofovir tdf
during the last trimester to bring the
viral load down so the baby doesn't get
infected and it's quite effective
if you combine tenofovir with a sub q
injection which would be her case or a
case
you know try to have it in the arm but
those would be
an important place for talking about
application
of vaccination at birth
newborns should get the vaccine within
two hours a lot of the guidelines say 24
hours but if you use two hours
it's very likely the country the patient
wouldn't need hepatitis b and being
globulin
so we talked about hepatitis b
vaccination and we talked about
hepatitis a vaccination
of course these are very very important
there's been a big impact of hepatitis b
testing treatment and vaccination
from cova 19 is what the health
departments are saying in terms of
a year previously unfortunately
this provider outreach on the top
83 is okay
community outreach at 82 but look at
advertise a vaccination you know way
down hepatitis c
linkage to care very far down stopping
surveillance testing
um obsessed a outbreak response terrible
san diego's big problem with hepatitis a
epidemic
so i think we are at a wrap i
wanted to move to q and a i want to
thank uh
the lab roots team for helping with this
the diastole
great to work with and we'll follow that
[Music]
around
thank you so much thank you so much dr
gish for your
presentation we will now begin the live
q a portion of the webinar and if you
have any questions you'd like to ask
please do so now
just click on that ask a question box
located on the left of your screen
and we'll answer as many questions as we
applied for
so let's take a look at what our
questions are coming already in
dr gish is hdv testing a true
need based on the low prevalence of
hbv in the us are globally
there are hdv tests available but in the
u.s
there is not an fda approved option
great question michelle i'd like to
clarify
approval as you know in the united
states there's multiple ways to access
testing including what are called ldt's
and
clia approved testing as well as what we
call
fda clearance for diagnostics
and fortunately there are delta tests
that are available in the us
through reference laboratories currently
through quest specifically
i know lab core has things in
development for delta antibody and delta
pcr
even without the fda clearance most
people should have access to antibody
testing and then reflex
the pcr testing so i think that's very
very helpful
and yes i believe that the
our hepatitis b foundation advice is
that everybody
who is surface antigen positive should
be screened for delta
with a delta antibody test and the delta
prevalence in the us
runs around six to seven percent in the
surface antigen positive population
and because it's 70 percent fatal
progressive
cancer death transplant we believe that
the hepatitis b foundation
is simple just to make sure every
hepatitis b patient has a delta test in
their chart
we think it's much more effective than
risk-based screening which as you know
failed for hiv failed for hepatitis c
it failed for hepatitis b so why do our
you know advisory panels keep talking
about risk-based testing
when the peer-reviewed evidence is that
it has failed
so test all is the final statement
thank you so much and dr kish what is
your recommended algorithm
for testing hepatitis delta would you
also use regime so the igm
test for delta should only be used in
somebody who presents with very
clear acute viral hepatitis
i think that's an important point i
don't use igm for general screening it
should be
total antibody which basically is going
to screen for igg
i do think there's some sensitivity for
igm and the total antibody
and we think that that antibody test is
around 95
sensitive that it might miss delta 5
of the time although that's still being
worked out it's a very good screening
test
thank you so much now at first i want to
thank our audience for these great
questions coming in
dr fish do you believe the increased
screening for hepatitis
b with have an overall health economic
benefit um for providers in or
laboratories so
we have to think about health benefit
health cost
if somebody is delta infected with a 70
chance of dying of cirrhosis needing a
transplant
developing cancer a test that's in the
20 to 50 range is phenomenally cost
effective and probably even cost savings
so from simple modeling this is the
right thing to do
we're on a path to eliminating viral
hepatitis
in the world with who with the recent
proclamation from president biden with
the cdc
buy-in on the elimination program and if
you don't test
you can't eliminate along those lines
people say well there's no
treatment then why would you test well
first off
treatment doesn't necessarily mean an
injection or a pill
treatment means advice about lifestyle
decreasing infectivity to other people
including decreasing or stopping alcohol
intake or if they have fatty liver uh
you know managing metabolic syndrome
lifestyle issues so treatment is a
really broad
term and we really need not to focus
on pills or injections is the only form
of treatment
and there is a treatment today for delta
it's interferon therapy
it's available there's peer-reviewed
publications
that cover this and clearly show a cure
rate
meaning a maintained viral negativity
i'm not going to use the word cure in
the big sense but maintaining the virus
is negative
in the 15 to 20 percent of patients then
another subset of patients have a reset
and their
viral load their dna hepatitis b
sorry hepatitis delta rna test
so when the rna gets reset by two logs
or more down
outcomes are better that's been shown
also in a paper by patricia farsi i
think that was the one in new england
journal of medicine
so there's lots we can do also if you
have somebody with delta you're going to
manage them and monitor them more
frequently than a hepatitis b
patient so delta testing means linkage
to care
good care is a variety of different
interventions
treatment as a variety of different
interventions
thank you so much and it looks like we
have one more question coming in from
our audience
the cdc described patients with
negative and anti-hbc positive
and ash anti-hp as
positive to be immune due to hbv
infections do you think the description
is misleading
considering that patients can have hpv
reactivation
that is a fantastic question and what
you're reading is some
very old information from the cdc
website if you're finding that
currently i would need to find the web
link and go back to the cdc
and have them hopefully delete that or
archive that
when you're core positive it means
exposure
core antibody positive means that
there's ccc
dna residual virus in the liver
when there's surface antibody positive
with core
that's not natural immunity that's not
immune
due to hepatitis b infection you're
exactly correct this is the wrong term
we call it immune control so the higher
the surface antibody
positivity and somebody who's core
positive
just means that the immune system has
better control of the hepatitis b
infection and a lower risk of
reactivation
so core only that's highest risk for
reactivation and can also define occult
hepatitis b
core plus surface the higher the surface
antibody tighter
the lower the risk of reactivation so
let's use the word immune control get
rid of the word
natural immunity which is an oxymoron or
immune due to happy infection and if you
find that somewhere
shoot me the link by email and i will go
to the source and have that corrected
fantastic point dr gish i want to thank
you for your presentation
today would you like to provide any
closing remarks for our audience
uh there's another question in the chat
box about
quantitative s antigen and that
is available there's a quant s available
both through quest
and lab core now and i ordered that and
have been ordering that on all of my
patients
dating back three years or four years
from quest and then
this year from lab core so quantitative
anagen i believe is the standard of
quick care once a year in all of your
hepatitis b
patients whether they're on or off
treatment
i think you're going to find the
guidelines are going to be updated this
year from easel
concerning this i just talked to pietro
lempertico about that who wrote the
guidelines
and then hopefully asld will update
theirs and be very specific
you have to think there's over 200
articles in the publication in the
literature
about how to use quantitative surface
antigen
to help profile patients clinical status
their infectivity
the risk for liver cancer on treatment
response
are they clearing hepatitis b naturally
there's some relationship to infectivity
that partners with hpv dna levels
so yes you can order it today i strongly
recommend you order that and have that
on your b
patients and track trajectory of surface
antigen status
and there's one more question michelle
if i can jump to the one about anti-hbs
for protection
so this is a great question so
anti-hbs alone if positive
means that that person's been vaccinated
there's no way to develop surface
antibody
without having exposure or without
having
a vaccine now there's a little bit of
variation in the literature about
what that level of protection is but i
like to use the number 15
i use so if it's measurable at 15 iu's
or above
that person's had a vaccine response
but i'd like to highlight that all of
the vaccines are both
b cell vaccines and t vaccines
so when you give hepatitis b vaccination
whether it be
the three dose indirects or three dose
recombinax or the two dose
heplicafb which is what i use in my
practice
you're stimulating t cell and b cells
we can't measure the t cell immunity
clinically
but in research we have extensive data
on t
cell responses so when people get
hepatitis b
vaccine two or three doses they don't
even need to check
a surface antibody level except in very
special patients
who is special in this setting be
dialysis patients
hiv patients or health care workers with
extensive blood exposure
even then we're not really sure that
checking helps that patient
but it is part of the protocol today and
those
very narrow populations
are the only groups that need boosters
so when you vaccinate with two doses you
vaccinate with three doses whichever
vaccine you're using
you do not need to check a titer they're
vaccinated for life according to what we
know and for life means protection goes
out now
30 years according to published
published data
only people you need to retest would be
babies born to a mom with hepatitis b
and then these other few special patient
populations and that's covered very well
at the cdc website they've done a
really good job updating terminology
updating advice
i had some differences with the cdc in
the past and i communicated that to
leadership there
they really brought their website up to
current definitions
of these tests what they mean what to do
about vaccine
the cdc is doing a fantastic job just
like they are with our
covet epidemic
[Music]
dr dr gish thank you so much for your
time today
and for your important research i also
want to thank
lab roots and our sponsor via soren for
underwriting today's educational
webcast and before we go i want to thank
you audience for joining us today
and for your interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period
will be addressed by our speaker via the
contact information
that you provided during registration
and this webcast
can be viewed on-demand elaborates will
alert you via email when it's available
for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's
live event until next time take care
everyone stay healthy
bye